India is the world's largest democracy  and this is the world's largest election  815 million voters more than every man  woman and child in all of North America  and Europe bill be casting their ballots  in nine rounds of voting over the next  five weeks at a million polling stations  equipped with almost two million  electronic voting machines their job  choose more than 500 lawmakers and the  party that will run the world's  tenth-largest economy whoever wins rules  a country that's home to almost  one-fifth of the world's people anxious  about an economy in its worst shape in a  decade even as prices rise by ten  percent a year India a colossal country  and a colossal challenge